how many times were brand managers who
have so many other duties on top of
being the one who judges subjectively if
this video is nice how many times did he
or she say not that one that one and it
was actually the other one that would
have changed their business I think that
we are crippled by a fantasy in
corporate America marketing that doesn't
exist it's no different than voice this
needs to be on voice I'm brand cool
who's the judge in the jury of it being
on brand because I know everybody in
here either has done this or has been on
the other side of this which is the
brand is snarky Rick thinks you're
creative is snarky he goes on as normal
18-month rotation sally walks in and
goes what is this crap this isn't snarky
you know and most of all we have
audacity do you know what audacity is we
have insane audacity in our ivory towers
of marketing thinking we know what
people want first of all there's 87 to
4,000 different psychographic clusters
of the people that are seeing this which
is the point which is I to answer your
question 2017 make six commercials make
them two minutes long actually make them
creative not commercials make them a
documentary type thing or a sitcom type
thing or a music video thing actually
star the people that you're trying to
reach in it so you know I always say
this so my friends are like why do you
think BG over index's with
african-americans they're in it like if
you want a Latina woman to buy your
product why don't you put one in the
video and then this is crazy stick with
me this is nuts and then you mark it to
Latino women and they actually see it
it's crazy you can do this now it's
called Facebook right and I don't you
know honestly I feel like jumping out
the window right now
[Music]